are they like LARPing as Barnacles
they're just stuck at that
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is this what is this describe what
you're seeing
is that a man sitting on oh no way
there's a dude on there whoa holy [ __ ]
so it's a big ass cargo ship is that the
rudder and there's people on the oh
there's three that's a Somalian pirate
oh damn they're hitching right on look
at that part is three of them do you
think it's like the world's worst
Pirates and like oh [ __ ] we can't climb
up I thought this was gonna work
our Sabers are weighing us down are they
like LARPing as Barnacles
they're just stuck at that
they're doing that too but that means I
gotta be doing that facing the [ __ ] yeah
maybe when someone was like Hey you know
you know girls like guys with muscles
and then they became muscles
they're so dedicated to the incorrect
thing you didn't like that I had to do
it I had to do that minus one I had to
do that one sorry for the last minute of
this video this is Community Theater
warm up yeah yeah we're a little cold
okay we haven't seen each other in a
while that's great
um so yeah the uh it's not clear whether
these three men spent the entire Journey
on the boat's Rudder but this is how
they were found they are three stowaways
um they are from uh
this ship was coming from Nigeria
they've been transferred to the port and
treated by Health Services for like
dehydration and stuff like that whoa
terrible with all that water around
drink water yeah what a bunch of
geniuses but this this ship was uh
that's Twitter response it took 11 days
11 days 11 days dude they survived Jesus
but that's why it's not clear that they
were just chilling on the rudder the
whole time when do you when do you get
on a runner yeah when do you get on it
yeah how do you get on road that's why
yeah that would be my question or unless
they got inside somehow and then they
were just stuck at the bottom and they
saw maybe some sunlight and like oh [ __ ]
maybe we can like climb out yeah go
somewhere and then they climb to where
the rudder was like oh just kind of
connects let's get some stuff what
happens if the water is just a little
bit choppy
[ __ ] dude yeah but they're kind of
barnacles so they're stuck yeah bottom
of the boat did you see there were a
little more seating though they can't
even sit straight like that because of
the the the way that it's shaped they
had to be like this and I bet you when
the rudder moves they gotta go like even
like that whoa they're gonna duck out
yeah isn't there like a [ __ ] gigantic
propeller are just under there too like
you can't just dip in real quick yeah
yeah that's why I feel like they were
inside and then they came outside and
then they have to be able to go inside
because if it gets choppy I guess it
would make sense that there has to be
some sort of inside access to the rudder
directly yeah yeah just in case
something got caught on it and they
could have started with 10 dudes and
there was only three left the other
one's doing exactly that scares they
kept pushing off the rest of the guy you
know I feel like I run it out we should
change our immigration laws to the more
extreme your situation was you just
automatic you get a free pass because
like legendary status yeah because then
you know these dudes they're they're
tough they're gonna hustle yeah they're
gonna Hustle Hard they're not gonna come
in and be a little [ __ ] they're gonna
be like dude I was on a Rudder for 11
days yeah and they got a social media
start already and I mean a little quick
quick trip to notoriety yeah we should
make those guys Instagram celebrities
bro you know what I mean because their
their story is probably way cooler this
is like when people are like we should
be paying teachers what they pay LeBron
James and then everyone's like yeah it's
like cool it's a pretty dumb [ __ ]
idea actually
there's only one LeBron James too you
can't actually can't pay them that much
well they don't understand math so it's
okay well they're feeling the effects of
inflation pretty hard I think maybe
they'll learn that one so it's LeBron
LeBron's a hurting right now he's
[ __ ] bummed out about it there's
apparently uh 20 in the UK there's
around 24 000 people who are detained in
Immigration centers every year so take
out the ones that work the hardest to
get there and keep them the ones with
the cool stories yeah love it
I guess that's a solution I I look like
you didn't write this in the article I
love it because we don't have to govern
we can just come up with the solution
say they should do that and we get to
walk away that's good yeah yeah we don't
get to feel the repercussions I mean
that's what being a citizen is all about
you just make decisions and they do the
work figure it out idiots yeah right we
get to vote do better um do you guys
parents have crazy immigration stories
maybe you're like great great great
great great grandparents
um I probably fall asleep listen to them
tell the story so I don't know I have no
yeah my parents don't stop reminding me
how much they had to save up and get a
nice ticket on an airplane to come to
America so they got a nice ticket a nice
ticket they saved up got first class and
came to America or what it was economy
plus oh wow my grandma was telling me
one time about how like her grandparents
came to America but then I was like huh
sorry uh not at off there you're
your pants
uh specifically Coming to America
nothing was really really crazy I think
escaping Vietnam there are some crazy
stories getting out of there but then
like by the time they got like sponsored
however like were able to come over to
Hawaii and whatnot like everything was
pretty okay
um but I do remember like my mom had
said that uh one time when they were
like escaping Vietnam during the war
she was just like a little boat like a
little kayak or canoe or some type of
[ __ ] right uh with her grand auntie and
uh during that time
um they were they were you know not
[ __ ] Jack sparrows but there were
pirates they're like constantly in the
waters and stuff like that you know
um and uh apparently this sounded really
crazy as I recount this but my mom and
her grand Auntie were like in a boat and
uh they saw a bigger pirate ship but
there was hella fog right so it wasn't
like clear who could be seen or if they
could be uh if they were even being seen
by the pirate ships or or anything like
that but apparently my my mom's Granite
they got so scared and Grand Nancy might
not be blood like you know they just
called them oh yeah yeah might not be
I'm not sure yeah but apparently Granite
got so scared she got a heart attack
died on that boat oh no from Fear yeah
well I was just riding with like a dead
body in a boat trying to hide from
[ __ ] pirates in the fog so she had a
paddle by herself with a dead I don't
know if it was a paddle boat could have
been a swan yeah it was probably a swan
so she had [ __ ] do one of these and
she ends up in Echo Park yeah
it's a one-way ticket
and you need both sides right so if
you're only on one side you keep going
in circles she's just crying by herself
with a dead body just going in circles
homie the Pirates will catcher damn dude
look that's wild that's what's telling a
beautiful story is like in this room
look imagine the power
and then the Pirates have so much
mascara in their eyes I can't really see
them very well
I tell you I tell you did I mention my
dad's Story one time there's a
um I was talking about how I was like uh
one one a couple years ago I asked my
dad I was like Dad did you ever
you ever love anybody outside of Mom oh
yeah I was like what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what a winning answer that it's a
grown-up conversation that is your dad
why would you even ask him that I just
wanted to ask him your dad's a sex
opportunity
um and then he's like he's like yeah you
stayed at her house and I was like whoa
what
one
whoa and then he goes he goes yeah Mom
did too we were there that one time I
was like wait what and he's like back in
Vietnam in like 2002 my whole family
went to Vietnam went to this remote area
stayed at this like one family's house
so I do remember meeting this lady she
has the kids and stuff and all that
stuff they all look like you exactly you
might need to do a 23andMe
that's there how they greet each other
welcome Anthony damn they all have
tattoos yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they're
all [ __ ] popping and lock and
wiggling around and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then
um [ __ ] uh so he's like yeah you stay
at the hospital I was like dang you took
Mom to like your ex-girlfriend's house
we all sat there and said yeah you know
and then I was like what happened
and he just says it nonchalantly because
he doesn't know how to [ __ ] add
emotional like tone to anything
um and then he's like he's like oh well
you know uh during the war
you know I me and her were together and
then uh there was just a time where we
had to leave and then so I had to get
into a boat uh and with my family and I
was like come on let's go and then she's
like no I can't I can't leave my family
so uh that was it whoa damn holy [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I thought it was gonna be like
right anime story he's like well I was
going in her [ __ ] and then she [ __ ]
all over my [ __ ]
is that matter of fact right he's like
and then I was like yeah I don't think I
could do this anymore like why aren't
you telling your son that
that is not the way of the lead so
oh yeah so does your dad have two
families
just because just because of the butt
sex that's how it is they never did
vaginal dude but no there was just
literally a moment where it's like hey
we gotta go right now it's like my
family's leaving he's like no I can't
because my family's not going to have to
say so in that end of the relationship
but what makes him go back to her and I
guess he stayed in touch like way later
like after after my dad had come to
America and stuff like that they were
able to get in touch and stuff but it
was already over it's like they were
stuck in Vietnam and at that time too if
you didn't somehow already Escape so to
speak yeah to come from uh the you know
when Vietnam Was Won by the north to
come from Vietnam to come over like that
was a whole different experience he had
to get sponsored in a certain way like
you know what I mean like it's a whole
process
um it my whole my mom's whole family
basically couldn't get out and it took
her like 15 years to get old sponsorship
to get one of my aunties out of like
eight from my mom's side over to
California that took forever I remember
that process and she had my auntie had
to live with my my family for like years
and stuff and they like got she my
auntie got my room so I was like super
[ __ ] resentful for like as a young
kid for like a long time yeah that sucks
it's just one of those things you know
um but yeah it was it was just one of
those crazy like yo that's that's how
you guys broke up I I would send a text
message back in the day but yeah that's
[ __ ] sad dude that's crazy do you
think he loved her more than your moment
did you ask him it depends on the butt
sex really
that was a deal breaker it ruined it
yeah